Прощальний візит Анґели Меркель в Москву і Київ
здивував західних політологів тим, що навіть за кілька тижнів
до кінця її правління на посаді канцлерки ФРН, і в Москві, і в Києві
до неї уважно прислухаються і ставляться як до впливової політикині,
яка все ще може багато чого домогтися.
Щодо Росії Меркель хотіла показати, що вона буде шукати діалог з Москвою
до останніх днів на посаді канцлерки. А що стосується України,
вона намагалася показати, що ця країна продовжує відігравати важливу роль
і для неї особисто, і для майбутнього уряду Німеччини.
І це важливий сигнал, в тому числі і для Росії.
На думку політолога Ганса-Геннінґа Шредера, Меркель розуміє,
що мине чимало часу, перш ніж Берлін після виборів до Бундестагу
знову зможе відігравати активну роль посередника між Москвою і Києвом.
Чимало часу може зайняти формування коаліції. Тому для канцлерки було важливо
обговорити з Путіним і Зеленським такі теми, як конфлікт на Сході України
і транзит російського газу через Україну після запуску газопроводу "Північний потік-2".
Для Меркель відносини між Німеччиною, Росією і Україною - це тема,
в якій вона дуже добре розбирається і прекрасно поінформована.
В кінці прес-конференції після зустрічі з Путіним вона дала зрозуміти,
що спробує організувати ще один саміт у нормандському форматі.
Але на даний момент я не бачу, щоб з'явилися нові аспекти, які могли б призвести до результату.
На думку Сюзан Стюарт, для канцлерки Німеччини також було важливо
особисто обговорити з Путіним і Зеленським підсумки угоди між Берліном і Вашингтоном
щодо газогону "Північний потік-2".
Усі сигнали вказують на те, що Німеччина спробує зробити все можливе,
щоб продовжити цей транзитний договір. Зрозуміло, що це буде неймовірно складно,
тому що Москва, звісно, в цьому не зацікавлена. Але Берлін не погодиться з тим,
що з російської сторони такої зацікавленості нема.
Однак політолог Ганс-Геннінґ Шредер вважає, що це питання
повністю залежить від Кремля, а у Німеччини мало можливостей
вплинути на рішення Москви щодо транзиту газу через Україну.
Наразі у Німеччині взагалі-то немає іншого важеля тиску,
крім як перекрити газовий кран - тобто припинити купувати газ у Росії.
Це масивний важіль тиску, але досі жоден німецький уряд до нього не вдавався.
Меркель завуальовано погрожує до нього вдатися, кажучи, що якщо Росія
припинить транзит газу через Україну, тоді ми будемо змушені ввести санкції.
І в даному випадку може йтися лише про те, щоб припинити купувати газ у Росії.
Експерт нагадав про те, що цього літа "Газпром" постачав менше газу,
ніж передбачено контрактом. На його думку, Москва таким чином,
імовірно, готується до можливого конфлікту з Німеччиною
через транзит газу територією України.